So how should you go about thinking about implementing generalization.
You certainly want to be able to take advantage of whatever inheritance feature
is in your programming language. You just need to stick to certain rules.
Typically, this means that in children classes, you can add features, but
you don't want to take away features. And you want to really restrict how you do
any kind of overriding, in the child class. When you do want to override
a method in the child class, make sure that you obey the two following rules.
First of all, when calling that particular method, you want to make sure that
the child method can accept any arguments that the parents method could accept.
That is, the child has to be as open to inputs as the parent does.
Secondly, the output produced by the child method,
when given the same arguments that were given to the parent method should
produce the same result. What we're saying with both these rules is that for
the same situation in the parent, the child needs to do the same thing.
It needs to be, a special case. Now the child can do more.
If the child is handling a special case of the parent it,
it can deal with that particular special case. It just has to always,
act as if it is, it is also obeying whatever rules it specified for the parent.